that we would not decree
anything upon him That is that
left his people
Paul and other people to Islam.
Because his people were
unresponsive. He did not have
permission from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to leave his post.
And so, he left thinking that
Allah would not decree anything
upon him. Meaning, that he
didn't really think much of it.
He didn't assume that it would
be a prohibition or
disobedience on his behalf.
Though it was and so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala decreed
that the will swallow him. He
called out to Allah from the
midst of the darknesses There
is no deity. There is none
worthy of worship but you
exalted are you. Indeed I have
been of the wrongdoers. Allah
responded to his call He said,
so we responded to him and
saved him from the distress and
thus, do we save the believers?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
goes to goes on to mention the
story of Zacharia. says and
mentions Zacharia when he
called to his lord. Saying, my
lord, do not leave me alone
with no air. While you are the
best of inheritors.
Was very old when he made this
dua. and his wife was barren,
unable to bear children and so
Zacharia Ali Islam made dua for
a son to be his heir,
so that upon his departure from
this world, he would have
someone to take his place.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
so we responded to him. And we
gave to him John is translated
as John in English. An amended
for him his wife. Meaning that
she was barren, unable to bear
children, and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. relieved her of
that. Allah then describes the
reasons that caused this
response from Allah. The
reasons that brought on the the
response of Allah to his Dua to
his supplication. He said,
indeed, they used to hasten to
good deeds. And worship us in
hope and fear. And they were to
us humbly submissive. These are
the characteristics of those
whom Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
accepts their dua and answers
their prayers. He then goes on
to mention Mariam Alaihi Salam
and Aisa. He says and mention
the one who guarded her
chastity. This is a reference
to Mariam Alaihi Salam. Though
we blew into her garment
through our angel Jibreel and
we made her and her son a sign
for the world. Indeed, this,
your religion one religion and
I am your lord so worship me
at religion is submission to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala alone
without any partners. The
worship of Allah alone without
any partners and we see the
entire the entire heritage of
all of the prophets and
messengers is the same heritage
and that is your religion is
one and I am your lord so
worship me. This is the this is
the heritage of all of the
prophets and messengers. Law
says, and yet they divided
their affair. Meaning, people
after these messengers, they
carried on their legacy
efficiently and they changed
these religions and they became
partisan and they schismed. He
says, subhanahu wa ta'ala And
yet they, meaning those who
inherited the prophets and
messengers, who came after
them, divided their religion
among themselves. Allah says,
but all to us will return,
meaning all of them are
differing with one another This
one judges this, this group,
judges, judges this group
negatively, and this,
negatively and so forth yet to
all of them, all of us will
will return to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and be judged by the
only one who has right to
judge. Absolutely. He says,
regarding this judgment, So
whoever does righteous deeds
while he is a believer.
Meaning, he is worshiping Allah
alone without any part
partners. No denial will there
be for his effort. This person
will not? will not,
be missing any of his reward.
None of his reward will be
denied. and indeed we, of it,
are recorders, meaning that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
records meticulously all things
that we do and say. and this is
also to mean that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has written
this before the creations of
the heavens and the earth in
the preserved tablets. We'll
continue from there tomorrow
inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]